Set the title,
the category rather.
Okay,
good.
Think I got it right. Selfware and game
development. Perfect.
Okay, let me flip the screen over.
Um,
the plan today,
we need to finish figuring out the
structure of this thing, which I think
it's just going to end up being like no
structure.
That's usually the right answer.
I want to get it working end to end
and then we can start cleaning up the um
individual files. So
why do I have this mic so close to my
face
there?
So the first question I suppose here,
how chunky do we want the puffer lip
file?
What if we say if this Okay, if this
file were to leave
and this file,
we just have one, two,
let's say three,
four,
six,
like seven or eight files.
So it would basically be
config
into puffer lib.
This goes to algoore or whatever.
Merge this with models.
Oh, models went in here as well, didn't
it?
Okay, I can see this working.
I'm trying to see if we can drain this
into this.
What's up today?
Um, the big refactor.
Like we have all of Pover into C and
CUDA. It's very messy. I've hand edited
some of it. Some of it is still just
crap. Why we have this here? Um,
as it really is mucking through sewage,
but I'd like today to get the file
structure correct. I want the files to
basically be the code that should be in
each file is in the appropriate file.
And we essentially will be ready to
start just cutting stuff without having
to move more stuff.
self play. It works.
We're using it professionally.
Um, selfplay was the reason for all of
this though. Like the reason this had to
be done, well this was always going to
happen eventually, but it was likely
going to happen after Puffer 5, but Sol
play just added like plus 1.5k lines of
Python and um it essentially just
doubled the amount of Python that we had
to deal with and it's just too much.
Like screw it. I'm not dealing with that
much [ __ ] Python. It's just all
going into nice cud to see and we're
going to stop having dumb issues because
of having two languages that don't play
nicely together.
question.
Wait, what? What question? Self Oh,
status. I answered already. I mean, it
works. Um, we have the Robo selfplay
branch.
We're currently doing client work based
off of the
uh off of the contents of that branch.
And then what I'm working on now is just
a refactor starting from that branch
pulling everything into C and CUDA.
Oh yeah. Does Twitch still not let you
rewind?
It's still going to have to be on me to
um
cut the size of the back end, right?
I guess we could do
I'll go infra Huh?
This day is separate. We're getting to
something that I don't hate though,
which is this is progress.
I do think we are going to have the
question of whether we want to keep
I'll go separate.
Uh, so Jess, the league thing is just
for doing sweeps
and
uh since you have the Maya evals, I
would definitely just keep the Maya
evals.
I'd actually be curious to see if you've
had any sort of weird inconsistencies or
things that feel off with the chess
stuff because you have way better evals
for chess than we could possibly have um
for other areas.
Okay, we were at 13024. We'll see what
it ends up being after.
Uh, sweep got reworked in order to
better support selfplay. So, like a lot
of selfplay ends, you don't have access
to very good consistent evals. Even in
Roocode where you have a bunch of
scripted bots, it's kind of just tough
because everything's very
non-transitive.
So, we have now the thing that computes
ELO against all the other policies in
this sweep. That's the main thing.
And that lets you find more robust
policies over time.
It's not that um opponent diversity
isn't an issue. It is a major issue.
It's that none of the common
off-the-shelf things that are supposed
to help with that actually work. So, we
kind of kick it a layer down to you have
to probably just train against a bunch
of different opponents. you need to like
randomize some reward functions
depending on how much diversity comes
just naturally from your task itself.
There wasn't anything that we saw with
like exploer agents or historical or
anything that just fixed that for you. I
will say
It's an open research problem and I also
I've lost a lot of faith in the uh the
approaches that were used for this back
in the day. I think that they basically
just did a bunch of edge on their
specific problem
and then they presented their methods as
though they were much more general.
dashboard kernels in VEN for the last
major questions.
So I guess then the main thing is
probably everything just get goes into
puffer lip.
And then this becomes 7 to 8,000 lines.
So I guess the core question here,
right? I could take the model muon the
loss function
numeric kernels.
I could take all that stuff out and I
could put it into an algo.cu.
So we would get like two files instead
of one giant one. I don't want to split
it any more than that.
So,
we'll see how this works.
and we'll see if it's a clean split or
not. If it's an obviously clean split,
then uh we'll do it that way. And if
it's not, then we'll just make big
chunky file.
Oh, yeah. This is um a good call.
Most of AI is just it's really not.
I guess a lot of the big lab stuff is,
but
most of AI is just [ __ ] hard
engineering combined with um
having some research and algo
fundamentals.
how things been going. Huffer is doing
amazingly well, I'd say, on our research
and infra side. It's just a huge amount
of work. It really is a huge amount of
work. I've had a few just really rough
weeks here and there with um uh I really
do not enjoy this stupid type [ __ ] into
codeex loop. I actually this I what I'm
doing here I don't mind as much because
I know it's not actively screwing my
code, right? This is literally just
glorified copying and pasting from one
file into another right now for code
that's already there. That's fine. But
whenever I have to do any actual like
code stuff with codeex, it's so bad. Um,
it's unfortunately slightly more
productive to do it this way because of
how this refactor is going,
but I'm really really looking forward to
getting the code into a spot where it's
just easily manually editable.
If this works, Vend will also end up
going into puffer puffer. It'll puffer
lib gets renamed. This will be
pufferl.cu. Do you
Okay, that actually works. Look at that.
That's a nice split.
Let's just see if this is actually looks
like our research stuff. Uh, okay.
There's some kernels that need to be
moved, it looks like.
That's pretty good though.
I'm just like looking through seeing if
this stuff is like what I expected to be
in this file. So that's good. That's the
whole model.
I don't think it has the graphing in
here, which is good.
Muan optimizer.
some of the buffer stuff might move, but
this is a pretty good split.
to start with.
Bcash is knew what was moved there. Uh,
ignore that. So, this thing is this is
just for an experiment I'm doing on um
literally rendering the puffer fish
model. This is probably going to get
moved into like a single file includable
somewhere that you can use to be able to
have access to the puffer fish.
So you can completely ignore this.
So the only things that matter we have
algo all the algorithmic bits we've got
constellation as a standalone. This is
getting drained. This is the standalone
CPU demo.
This is our in loader.
This is getting dealt with. This is
probably going to stay separate. This is
like separate models. All of protein.
This will be the envi that you can
include. You get like a includable envi
now. Um just tiny littleh file. All of
the infrastructure. This is your
standalone CPU neural net file. Might
stick this into eval. Not sure yet. And
then this gets strained
Uhoh. Framework laptop sells out. I was
considering getting one of those.
Actually, does anybody have
recommendations on just like
not gigantic but reasonable
GPU
laptops?
It is really the case that like laptops
just suck these days.
5090. No, it doesn't need a 50. It just
needs an Nvidia GPU in it that will run
CUDA. It doesn't have to be a high-end
thing. It doesn't need to train fast or
something. You just need You really want
to have a device that can at least run
CUDA.
Yeah.
No,
you missed the mark.
MSI
probably don't need a gaming GPU. You do
though
because that's the Nvidia series, right?
See, I've always just bought Razer
laptops, and the thing is, they're very
nice, but they always have something
wrong with them. Whether it's the
battery blowing up, or my most recent
one that I have is like the trackpad
just doesn't work half the time. It's
kind of great.
I don't know. Maybe the entire laptop
form factor is just a joke
and we had it right the first time back
when everyone worked on desktops.
wreck.
Yeah, well, you need some sort of spot
to work and have a keyboard and monitor
plugged into something, and that
something needs to have a local GPU at
the very least.
I actually I find for my work normally,
to be fair, um, having a desktop with a
local 5090 is just awesome.
It's really nice.
Second best thing is having one you can
SSH into. You'll end up with a few
annoyances with that, but it's not that
Oh, yeah. I've heard the Dell XPS ones
are all right.
This looks pretty similar to mine. The
keyboard looks bad.
Um,
is that
bruh?
Like that's like a $2,000 laptop with no
graphics card.
Like that's a [ __ ] joke.
Like, all right. $2,000 for a paper
weight. Cool.
There's a GPU config. Do I even want to
know what it is if it's $2,000 for a
paper weight?
That's pounds. It's more two to one.
So $3,000 for a paper weight.
I mean, at some point the people they're
just taking a piss, right?
I mean, I'll show you my current one.
Hang on.
Like
if Razer would literally all they have
to do is just fix their awful awful QC
and they'd be good. Like look at this.
This is a 15-in 16inch laptop.
keyboard is not terrible on it. Whoops.
There. It's try. It thinks it's my face.
Uh, you can see it well enough, right?
Yeah.
Got a 5080 in it. That's more than
enough, right?
You can train like 15 mil SPS on it if
you want. It runs crazy hot if you use
the uh the dedicated graphics,
but I mean it's kind of what you'd
expect.
It's heavy, but it's not gigantic or
bulky or whatever.
But I don't recommend them because most
of the units, the trackpads don't work.
And I don't mean like I used it for 6
months and the trackpad didn't work. I
mean, I left it in the box for a couple
months, opened it, and was like, "Uh,
great.
XPS got shafted in the last two years."
Yeah, looks like it. Also, I don't
understand people's obsession with the
Mac style keyboards with the keys that
have like zero travel depth to them at
all. Those are just awful.
Like, you don't need to have the
thinnest possible laptop. You really
just don't.
You also don't need the lightest
possible laptop. Like, go lift a weight
or two.
It's not that bad to carry four or five
pounds. It's really not
Mhm. The keyboards I get are like okay
as well. I don't know if I'll just keep
getting these long term cuz there's
definitely better stuff you can get from
these.
Like all the Razor accessories are
generally just like decent, like okay,
except for the mice. The mice are
really, really good.
Okay. So with this
I'll go is here.
This is gone.
This stays.
And I think we're down to exactly what I
want. Right.
Look at that.
I'll go here.
Obviously, but we're going to go like
fix up individual stuff, but what do you
think of this?
is there a reasonable way to make
this includable?
What was in algo.cu?
So this is this basically you read this
file to understand all the details of
what makes our actual like research side
contributions worthwhile. So this has
the muon implementation. So that's our
optimizer. This has uh our model
architecture and our model like
structure and everything. This has all
of our numerics in it. This has our
advantage function.
This has our loss function. I guess
so though I suppose some of the loss
function could go back into pufferl.
I think I would generally prefer we take
like 500ish lines out of algo and put it
back into puffer lib. We have 5k infra
1.5k algo. That's a lot less
intimidating.
Yeah. I don't know why they make them
this shape.
They just make the profile of it really
shitty.
Uh, did they cheap the SSD
one? That's fine.
Yeah, something like that is pretty
reasonable.
The thing is, you never know how these
things play with Linux.
Is there still a market for that? Like
kind of tired, isn't it?
building a very fast game engine.
Well, it's not really an engine, per se.
Um, we do have our own stack for
everything, but when you go to build a
new game, you really don't have anywhere
near the constraints of a full engine.
Um, what you do have is just like a
bunch of lightweight tools that don't
put a huge amount of onus on how you dev
stuff. Uh, you write simple low-level
fast code and it works well. And our
paid work is mostly like directly
building simulators, not engine, for
specific problems. So instead of having
to have the company be able to figure
out how to get a team of their own
engineers to like build a sim for their
use case, they can actually just hire us
to build the sim and even do um a good
amount of the RL for them directly. And
uh we've been quite successful on that
across a bunch of different problems.
The idea is pretty much look all our
stuff's open source.
You can go and use it directly for your
problems. But if you like what you see
and you're impressed by the engineering
and you think it would be very difficult
to do that in house, you can hire us to
do it for you for your application.
Okay.
Um this is cool, right? So you ignore
this file. This is just like whatever.
Then we end up with one 2 3 4 5 6 7
eight files.
No, we don't bill by the hour. We bill
by the job.
and then um the milestone price goes up
each update as we're able to do like
more and more we're able to tackle much
more valuable problems, harder problems
um with our current version of Puffer.
So like basically fixed amount of work
for us per milestone and uh price per
milestone goes up as puffer gets better.
The eventual goal is pretty much that we
just like, you know, we eventually just
consider taking on pretty big um client
projects.
And um aside from that, most of our
focus will go into like in-house
applications.
this is basically
we're going to probably move some code
from here into here, but I think this is
roughly the split.
What do we think of this, folks? This is
about the amount of code that I started
with.
But instead of having 19 files,
we now have eight eight files.
Standalone any loader.
This is where we put all sorts of custom
encoder crap. Installations are
dashboard. Al goes the standalone
protein for sweeps. Here's our envi.
Here's our core infrastructure
and pufferet. We'll rename this or
whatever this is. Uh we'll rename this.
This is our CPU.
Yeah, I think that this is roughly the
right thing.
Uh maybe we rename a couple of these
real quick.
We'll rename a couple of these probably
when I think of it, but I think that
this is Nice.
I'll be right back. Move the restroom
real quick and then we're going to start
on the actual refactors for the ends.
I actually I think about it. I think
that the loss probably does stay in the
algo,
but let's just have it do its first
quick pass before I start on uh on
edits.
It's kind of cool to think that this is
it though, right? This is all of Puffer.
Like literally,
that feels a lot better to me. Like,
imagine that we get this down by maybe a
th00and or 2,000 lines. We make sure
everything lives in the right place,
everything is clean. That would feel
like, you know, solid in my mind.
No, I love constellation so much.
H constellation is so nice. I do think
we're going to rewrite bits of it
though. I think that we might end up
doing um you know, there's some stuff
that it needs for sure. Um I I want to
do that when I'm like in a clear frame
of mind and I'm not going to be lazy and
just do codeex [ __ ] with it cuz
that's like a nice project to do by
hand.
It's just going to be improved over
time, right?
Hey, Jess. Um, this is what you've
missed.
Take a look.
Buffer rename. Oh, that's been a thing
for a while. I don't know why it wasn't
the file wasn't named that way.
airl.
Okay, so we're going to see what happens
as a result of this. Still a little bit
of moving stuff back and forth between
files to do, but I think this is the
right split now. Right. We have one file
for the algo, one file for
constellation, a standalone config
loader.
This is custom encoders,
all of protein, our CPU, evals, end of
API,
and our core infrastructure.
That seems like a minimal split where
you can't really you can't merge any of
these in a reasonable way.
Like there's not really a reasonable
argument for merging any of these
Nice. So, this just cuts about 100 lines
from algo and sticks them into uh
protein or I mean into uh buffer. That's
good.
can probably do the uh CPU binary as
well.
Oh, wait. Python wall time.
Huh?
Look at this.
No Python.
Also, I just want to show this off.
Oh, okay. Maybe it does get messed up.
[laughter]
Maybe it does get messed up. We'll fix
that.
It does get messed up a little bit.
[laughter]
But if you scroll to the bottom, at
least it doesn't write [ __ ] like in
place and get screwed up that way. Okay,
this Okay, look. At least it's easier to
fix it and see.
In Python, it's just like [ __ ] you. You
don't have control over the terminal
directly.
Do we log on everything? I forget. I
don't think we log every on everything,
Jess.
Oh, of a sweep.
I don't know about that one, man.
That might just be one of those features
where you're best off being like, I've
heard your suggestion.
It is declined.
I kind of just think of everything in
terms of the weight of the code.
Now, is it actually worth having that?
I don't think any I wouldn't use that.
If anything, the sweep should just have
its own little interface where it just
tells you like summary stats live so
far.
See, it's like user asks for X because
they want Y.
User asked for X but actually user wants
Y. Developer must be psychic.
Understand what user actually wants and
build thing for user.
Well, it actually should be way easier
to add stuff to Puffer now with this.
Like look at this. It's beautiful.
Eight files.
opt in stream notification. Subscribe
and click the bell.
Oh, can I implement a capture? So, the
bots
making a mess of
Do you need a capture for that?
I think they already have like that's
already implemented in the Discord, man.
like they just bypassed that [ __ ]
I mean, I think the only thing would be
like automod.
There's probably a pretty simple auto
mod you can get for it.
I mean, if you literally just had the
cheapest language model out there
auditing [ __ ] like, "Hey, go find any of
the like common asking does anybody need
an AI developer [ __ ] post by new
accounts.
Just simply tell me what tool you need
me to add and I'll add it and give you
permission to configure it.
message me up
the link or whatever.
Well,
this feels a lot less intimidating to
refactor,
but it's still a whole bunch of [ __ ] to
refactor, huh?
I guess we just start looking at um
we'll just start by looking at this
file.
I mean, I guess arguably we probably
want to have the um
No, we don't want to have stuff we don't
use actually.
trying to find what?
What error have you just posted? Yes.
Actually, there are numeric to this,
aren't there?
I actually think that we keep these in
here.
We can probably remove these depending.
No, we can't.
Um,
Oh,
was a joke. I think.
There's RLC as well, which is sometimes
decent.
Use the model that will actively cut
itself off because I use it for AI. No,
thank you.
No, it still does it. It just tells you
that it'll do it now.
They probably got some investor
pressure, which is good,
but
I still don't care to give them money.
It's bad enough having to give OpenAI
money.
It's not The thing is it's not like
there's been made no progress because
it's a hard problem. It's been made.
It's like there's been no progress made
because it's poorly posed and it's a
dumb approach.
Super Maven is generally just fine,
Jess.
The only feature request is disabling
multi-line completions or at least like
capping it to three lines or something
so it doesn't try to edit the whole damn
file at once.
Isn't it paywalled?
Um, it's grandfathered. It was always
paywalt, first of all. Like, you're
running inference on somebody else's
machine.
It's grandfathered for now.
I know. Hopefully, we'll just yell at
them to open source the damn model or
something if they eventually kill it.
I honestly suspect that that model would
be pretty cheap to train by today's
standards.
It's probably just like a pretty lean
model.
You can probably train it on a single
node and then just curate a um a very
nice set of training data for it
train it on like the Linux kernel before
people started using models.
like the snapshot of Linux kernel from
three years ago or whatever and just use
that as the whole training
We'll definitely iterate on this mess
here.
Nice. This has everything it should have
in it.
Um, wait, our advantage function.
We should probably
add a comment on this.
contributor to Puffer.
Yes, you absolutely can do that.
You've made a major contribution. Of
course, it needs more testing and stuff,
but we're integrating it, and it appears
to be a nice, very nice contribution.
If you want my personal endorsement,
that's going to have to wait until um
I've actually gone through stuff and we
see that this all works, you know, you
can absolutely write yourself in as a
contributor. And uh if I haven't
already, you can PR yourself to the
contributor list on um you just open a
PR on the not the puffer lib repo, but
the puffer.ai AI repo.
And believe it or not, the algo file is
basically done for now.
And um if you're going to say, "Well,
Joseph, you just like that's all AI
slop." No, it isn't.
The AI just pasted together chunks of
Puffer 4 that were already very
carefully manually tuned. Um I looked
through it. There's not like any
substantial bit whatsoever of AI code.
That's all just from Puffer 4. So, we
basically just use this to iteratively
cut and paste our stuff together until
we got here. There are sections that are
shitty AI ports. Um,
but the ALGO file is clean.
Of course, it doesn't work, which is a
big issue.
I probably just deleted something I
shouldn't have.
Oops.
Lol.
I trolled.
Make sure this trains. We'll commit
this.
Let me use the restroom real quick. Grab
a drink. Um,
give me like seconds first.
Give me like 60 seconds. One thing on
the side here.
Oh, actually that'll take me longer. So,
it's fine. I'll be right back.
That's honestly super nice
to basically know that we have a clean
2,000 lines of code that's split off
that is at least at the quality of 4.0.
You know, that's pretty nice to know.
probably before we majorly refactor
everything,
we should um get the end to end test
working at least.
Probably productive
Oh, we actually ended up uh with shorter
code. Nice.
I think this is probably time to pull it
onto the larger box
and try a self play.
probably the play.
That doesn't work. There's something
wrong.
Upper max one is connected.
Huh?
Is it puffer?
Am I stupid?
There it is.
Maybe it did just have to start.
Kind of don't
want to mess with this.
Sometimes it just falls off um GPU falls
off the Docker for some reason.
I've tried several times to fix this,
but it doesn't seem like there's
anything you can do in the container
itself. So,
even if I fix it for one of my machines,
you users will still have it. I fear
it's better just leave it
curriculum run.
Um we have not messed with the like
we haven't messed with the end of
details of neural MMO 3 since launch.
Random doubt from an undergrad student.
Okay, since it's from an undergrad
student, I will give you a serious
answer to this. So
if you want to follow the traditional
job path through traditional interviews,
unfortunately very important um
companies have absolutely no idea how to
hire people. So even though those two
things have essentially zero overlap
with programming skill whatsoever,
companies still use them.
Um, if you're trying to like
get good at research or you know learn
lowlevel or like build actual things,
not at all important.
I would probably fail most easy problems
um on those for reference and uh I build
some pretty crazy Thanks.
20 mil SPS train.
Very good.
Very very good.
Okay.
Well, this is nice that this uh this
runs.
I guess we can just let this run and
then pull it local.
We'll have to check sweeps. We'll have
to check lots of things still work,
right?
Well, we should probably just do quick
sweep on here as well, right?
I can just audit in the meantime, I
suppose.
Protein's going to be its own thing.
This is whatever.
So the innie the top of constellation
maybe
this is fine.
It's mostly all like I the vast majority
of the complexity I'd say 80% of what
needs to be reviewed maybe 70 because of
the any is just this puffer all file.
So
let's see how bad it is.
I ming it.
I go here and I'll go.
It's a bunch of crap, but I mean it's
kind of the same stuff I'm used to all
like this is just code from 40.
I would think config section should go
to the up.
Okay, some of this config stuff we know
needs to be cleaned up.
There's some shitty AI code in here.
again. All this is normal code like we
remember this is this is all our code.
It's just the glue between that it's
screwed with.
The rest of this is fine.
Oh, we're still in self play.
But I think
Well, I guess we'll see
where this is. Here.
How's this formatted? It's like this,
isn't it?
Yeah, it's a little annoying, But
Let it finish and then we'll email this.
Good. That's good progress.
through algo.
It has to be visible through algo before
ocean is included.
Huh?
100 mil run rate. What the [ __ ]
[laughter]
I mean like okay sure you can massively
like try [ __ ]
end of header still use.
Okay. So, it's just being stupid is the
thing.
Yeah. Yeah. It's just being stupid.
That's fine. We can fix this.
If we can at least get the file laid out
reasonably with like include sane so
that it's basically just function level
jank
um with some of the shitty ported code.
That would be a good accomplishment
today.
Okay, this is in this is like in
progress editing. So, I can't edit I
can't run this yet. Um.
got three hours as well to keep it.
Yeah, we should be able to like crank a
decent build today.
Like obviously there's still chunks of
the harness.
Um well, not the harness, that's the
wrong word. It's like the launcher and
the multiGPU and like the random
selfplay Python crap as well as like
config crap. Some of these are still
just AI ports um that are not up to the
quality standard.
But if we can at least get the layout to
be sane
today
where most of the code cleanup will just
come from tightening various chunks of
it rather than having to move stuff
around more. I think that that would be
nice.
The big code savings are probably like
it's going to probably be a few hundred
lines off of protein and like the
selfplay plus config system and stuff
like That
logar log as well. So we have what?
Envog
is fine.
Hey Jess.
Is that Jess testing one? Yes, just
welcome
welcome back.
Good.
So, we move the dict over to the puffer
API.
You just have a minimal dict. That's
fine.
All right, we'll see what stupid [ __ ] it
does next. But this is good.
Such a crit about it.
This is a casual stream.
I do not hold myself to uh professional
standards of conduct on stream.
This is like random Discord call
etiquette.
I think that's the uh the problem with a
lot of people that think that streaming
is exhausting.
It's like, well, yeah, if you're going
to try to be talking through stuff and
holding yourself to some reasonable
professional standard all day, sure. You
can also just not doing that.
Oh, [ __ ]
Um, it's not actually a So, it's not
really a a full dictionary is the thing.
It doesn't use hashing.
It's just like an O of N everything,
you know? It's just a key lookup.
It works like a dictionary, but it's
super slow. Cuz the thing is like any of
these things are going to be super slow
because hashing is also annoying.
Having a separate dictionary like dict
file seems so crap to Okay.
Okay, that's the macro gone. At least
slightly gross.
I mean, I could just edit them and be
like, "Hey, is this work?"
quicker.
And then act sizes as well.
Yeah, that's fine. I think I if we get
the order of this right, then it'll just
be reasonable
in it
I'm sure that I just did like wrong
order.
Oh, why did it have it? It had it
declared twice.
Stupid man.
It's It can't possibly be that dumb, can
it?
It's actually that dumb. That's
impressive.
I think I'm revising my opinion to like
it's not even like a particularly dumb
undergrad. It's a particularly dumb
underdeveloped high school student half
the time.
Exactly. You just have to for declare
the end.
Like so incredibly dumb.
Where is the entity encoder in CUDA? Is
that set up somewhere in a branch?
Um,
it was in the test file that I sent for
that, right?
Yeah. Okay. Twitter.
point linear max.
And then this builds against there's
some CUDA file in here. Here it is.
This one Spencer I didn't port it into
the um the CUDA yet cuz this basically
has to go into Ocean as a custom
encoder.
But this is what it would be.
I'm making progress by the way.
1300 lines, eight files
getting to be pretty clean. Algo is
clean already. Like Algo is as clean as
40.
Um,
working on NVPI a little bit. Most of
this is just the puffer fish. So, we can
cut this down.
And this is the big one here. There's
like I think maybe a total of 1,500ish
lines of AI gen config and glue to edit
and then there's obviously protein.
Not that bad though.
If you want to work on stuff for a bit,
let me know. I'm happy to like jam on um
some entity encoder stuff with you.
I don't like the startup time either. I
think we can cut this down.
Okay, this works.
Let's try to get that going. All right,
give me uh give me one minute to make
sure that this isn't totally screwed up
and I'll use the restroom and I'll hop
off for him.
I I don't understand how it's this dumb.
I really don't.
Like every so often it's just like
is this GPT2?
Yeah, it literally just doesn't
Whatever, man. That's fine.
All right, I am going to end stream here
though because I got to chat with
Spencer. So, um
uh we will continue the refactor streams
tomorrow most likely. For folks who have
been watching, thank you for tuning in.
Um there will be some more cool dev
after this refactor is done soon as
well. If you'd like to support my work
for absolutely free, buffer.ai I sorry
the GitHub be the puff or star helps a
lot. Uh Discord's where all that dev
happens. Join this to get involved and
you can follow me on X for more RL
content including educational stuff. Um,